The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Where
we are scientists--
I'm speaking as a
professional scientist--
and the wall they we're hitting
in communicating our science,
and having things
translate out of there--
I'm aware of a
paper that was just
published a few weeks ago
that's on the importance
of storytelling in science.
And that they found that some
published journal articles that
had more of a narrative
structure are getting
cited more because people
want to hear stories.
The dry, scientific, just
the facts aren't working.
They want to hear stories.
So I want to share
my story with you
about how I got involved
in this gas leak stuff,
and then I'll hand
the baton to Audrey,
and she'll take it from there.
But I started about this thing
about the methane gas leaks
as a citizen.
This started in
2010, November 2010,
for me, walking two blocks
away from our home in Newton,
in the Auburndale
village of Newton,
with my 10-year-old son,
who was 7 or 8 years old
at the time, Julian.
And two blocks
away from our home,
we came upon a gas
leak, and someone
who was working on gas leaks,
Bob Ackely, Gas Safety USA.
He's a 30-year
professional, non-scientist,
but that curiosity, what
are you doing there.
He looked like Ghostbusters
with a metal detector,
but it was a gas meter.
And that's how I got
involved in understanding
this problem with gas leaks.
So it was as a citizen.
And for me, that has
started a process
by which I've grown
as a scientist citizen
and come into a community
science framework,
working with Audrey and a
whole group of other citizens
in a community.
And we've defined,
I think, a community
that crosses all
types of boundaries
to address the
problem of gas leaks.
So from that first
chance citizen
kind of experience for me, till
2013, the science part of this
developed that we mapped out
over 3,000 of these gas leaks
in the city of Boston.
And then we followed it up with
a study in which we estimated
that the amount of gas being
lost in Eastern Massachusetts
amounted to about 10% of the
Commonwealth's greenhouse gas
emissions inventory.
So that propelled a coalition
of a community to then say,
how do we move our
political leaders
to actually create policy
to address this situation?
So it's been a really
fulfilling thing for me.
And I will say that the
science that we did, actually,
and what we published in
the journals, is not new.
The problem had been
known about for decades.
It's just that it was
not known to the public.
So we found citizen
after citizens
in different neighborhoods
of Boston that would say,
oh yeah, I know
about a gas leak.
I smell it every time I
go walking to the store.
And so what we
realized is that there
were hundreds of anecdotes
that were completely
siloed from each other.
And once we put a map
out there, the community,
everyone could see the
whole thing collectively
at the same time.
And that was the
only thing we did.
We just made it visible.
And Audrey took it
to the next step,
and I'll pass the baton to you.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: OK, thanks.
So I'm just going to
talk for one second
about what actually
gas leaks are, since--
from pipes under
the street, right?
So a lot of our pipes under
our street are really old.
Here's a close up detail of
back bay, a National Grid map,
very small detail of it,
and you can see that two
of the pipes running down--
the 1860 one is a pipe from
1860 running down Beacon Street.
And two streets away running
down Comm Ave is one from 1882.
And those pipes
are still in use.
So we've got some really
old infrastructure around.
The problem with gas leaks is,
they're potentially explosive.
This is a picture of the
explosion in Harlem about two
years ago, I think 2014.
As they gas percolates
up through the soil it,
pushes oxygen out
and trees actually
need to breathe oxygen
through their roots.
So they can die.
And then it's, as Nathan said,
a powerful greenhouse gas.
If you burn natural gas,
it's turned into CO2.
If you don't burn it,
it stays as methane.
Methane, on a
20-year time frame,
is 86 times more
damaging than CO2.
And finally, we
have to pay for it
because the utilities
can pass that cost
on to us, the ratepayers.
So it's sort of just insulting.
So when I read about
Nathan's first,
I run an energy
efficiency nonprofit.
And primarily, we used to work
in the buildings of nonprofits
to help them lower their energy
bills and energy emissions.
And so then, a lot
with Mass Save,
which is the state's
energy efficiency
state-funded program.
And so I read about
Nathan's research
when he surveyed all
of Boston and found
those over 3,300 gas leaks.
And there was one line
in the article that
said that the amount of gas
lost in just Boston alone
totally erased all of the
state's energy efficiency
programs.
And so I was that was it.
I was in.
So I called up Nathan
and said, how can I help?
And he was kind
enough to loan us
his extremely fancy
cool equipment, which
is called the Picarro High
Precision Natural Gas Analyzer.
And we drove it all over
Cambridge and Somerville.
So the yellow lines
are where we drove--
or not, we Bob Ackley--
drove.
And the spikes are where there
is elevated levels of methane
found.
And it's sort of fascinating.
We found no correlation between
income level of neighborhoods.
Because they're
just-- you'll see them
sort of somewhat
clustered together
because neighborhoods are
built at the same time,
generally, using the same
infrastructure, same material.
Here's what I call the
Alps of North Somerville.
And we will be going, we'll
be doing a leak survey
in the fantastic van
with the Picarro,
so you can come along and
see these on your own,
and do some surveying
on your own.
AUDIENCE: And smell it.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah, I
mean we can also smell--
see what's fascinating to
me, is like, near my house--
I would always bike
along the Charles,
and there was just
one huge gas leak
I would smell all the time.
And I would always
think, like, can't
be because I'm looking
around, and I'm
seeing all the other people,
and they're just walking by.
So I always thought, like,
I must just be making it up.
But then I called it in.
And it was fixed.
And after that, I
never smelled it again.
And that was so-- like we
just don't believe our noses.
So after we did the
Cambridge Somerville work,
I thought, we've got to
scale this up somehow.
I found some arcane data on the
Department of Public Utilities
site, where they have to give
a lot of information, including
this, which--
over 300 pages of
this sort of stuff.
But you'll see that there's
actually addresses there.
So as soon as I saw that
there were addresses
showing where the leaks were,
I thought, cool, I can map it.
So I mapped every gas leak in
Massachusetts on Google Maps,
so they're zoomable.
Anybody can see them
at squeakyleak.org.
The yellow map pins are where
the leaks are unrepaired,
and the reds are where they
were repaired the previous year.
And there's just a lot of them.
And this was some of the--
really transformative
for a lot of people,
because then they
could actually see
where the leaks were near their
home, near their kids school,
near their business, et cetera.
It made the, not only
invisible visible,
but it also made
the global local.
And then I'll finally finish
up with one last thing, which
is some other parts
of Nathan's research,
as well as Margaret
Hendrick, who
is a graduate student, a
postdoctoral student here
at BU, is they surveyed a
hundred gas leaks in Boston
to find that just 7% of them
emit 50% of the gas by volume.
So that means-- as soon as
you know that, you know,
OK, the whole thing is to
find and fix those leaks.
So through a lot of
work, through all
the different people who
are interested in this,
we managed to get,
we helped to get
a state law passed
that those leaks will
have to be found and fixed.
And so one of the things
we're going be doing
is, at the hackathon,
we'll hopefully
be trying to figure
out a method that's
utility friendly
for the utilities
to measure the emissions off of
each one of these theoretically
high volume leaks.
Because if we don't have
feedback for the system,
they're probably going to find
whatever leaks are convenient
and call those high
volume, and fix them.
Because they don't
know how to do it yet.
Nobody does-- how
to find the leaks.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Have you
checked on the response
of National Grid
or other utilities
about their capacity
to repair these leaks
and also compare that to the
new leaks that have emerged?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah, I met
with a lot of other people.
I met with National
Grid on Friday.
They say they've hired a
whole bunch of new people,
and they say they will have
the capacity to do this,
to fix all these leaks.
But what I want them
to do is be transparent
about their
information so anybody
can check that they
fixed the right leaks,
that the leaks were fixed, that
you know, so on and so forth.
Because the more
transparency we have,
the more researchers can look
at stuff and citizens can, too.
AUDIENCE: Is there color
coding near the [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY SCHULMAN: No, in
this case I was mapping,
the pink ones are
super-emitters,
the high-volume gas leaks.
The yellow ones are not.
They're just normal gas leaks.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Maybe
I'll just add something
about the community science
and the opportunities
for just being creative here.
And I think it's just is
embodied by the collaboration
that Audrey and I have so
well was, to do this study,
we had to think of
methods that were
a little out of the box, a
little bit about found objects
fortuitous stuff.
Because there's no real kit
to measure gas leaks that you
can buy from some-- we were
making this up as we go.
So, for example, we found out
that the best kind of chamber
to measure what's
coming out of man holes
is a turtle shell
from a sandbox.
So it fits right over
with a known volume,
and you get that for $20
instead of having a machine
shop make it for $1,000.
So there's that
level of creativity.
And just yesterday
Audrey came up
with the use of a pinwheel that
might be able the mix the air
that we need to measure.
And it's the kind
of thing that it's
like, once she said that, it's
like, yeah perfect, you know,
a pinwheel.
So I think, in the hackathon,
there will be opportunities
to think about how we might
go about doing something
in a cost-effective way
without doing it kind of like,
you know, NASA does in
their multimillion dollar
laboratories.
you find-- you had your test
going out with the truck.
And then you had the
DPU emissions data.
Did you find any leaks that were
not on the DPU National Grid
list?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Oh, yeah.
With Metropolitan Area Planning
Council, HEET, my nonprofit,
has done a survey of 15
different municipalities.
We found 1.7 times more leaks
than the utilities reported.
And there's lots of
other stuff that we
found that makes us
question the utility data.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Paul.
AUDIENCE: Nathan,
thank you [INAUDIBLE]
question and a comment.
Question, how do you know where
the super emitters are now
on the map, given
that you're still
in the process of
measuring, as I understand?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So we did this
survey, the driving survey,
that measured 3,356
leaks in Boston.
But that's just detecting leaks.
That doesn't tell us
how much is coming out.
So then subsequently to that,
we went out with these chambers.
Some of them were
the turtle shell.
Some of them were five gallon
buckets with a slot cut out
so it could go up to a curd.
Because sometimes it comes
out these complex geometries.
And so we did the laborious
task of going back
to 100 of those 3,356 leaks.
And measuring how much just
coming out using this chamber
technique.
And from that the statistics
of those 100 leaks
showed that seven
of them accounted
for 50% of the total lost gas.
AUDIENCE: So you've
done a sample, but not
comprehesive in any regard.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Exactly.
It might be more like-- if we
get the whole thing over again,
maybe pick another 100 leaks,
it may be that 10 of them
accounted for 50%, or maybe 6.
Right, it was a sample.
We know that it's not
a bell shaped curve,
and you've got an average leak.
And some were a
little bit higher.
little bit lower.
The distribution
has a long tail.
There's a few big ones.
And a lot of small ones.
AUDIENCE: Now my comment is
antecdotal, but it's true.
In one town that I was working
with, I won't name the town,
the report was that when
they had a gas leak,
and the citizen complained
enough, that they would exactly
come out and fix the leak.
But they didn't fix it
well the first time.
They sometimes have to come
back and do it five times.
And the reason for that
is that the gas companies
get paid based on the
amount of work that they do.
So if they do the same
work over and over again,
the get paid each time for it.
So as you're engaging in this
mentoring and monitoring,
I do completely
agree with the fact
that some amount of
oversight, or review,
or checking up on ones that
they say have been fixed
would be a good
part of the plan.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah,
I think transparency
and watchdogs are
good for any industry.
AUDIENCE: Have you projected,
just in a dream-like way,
how much gas could be
contained, and how much
that would reduce any demand?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: So
the best estimate
that we have for amount of
lost gas comes from a study
that we did in
collaboration with Harvard
University, Catherine McKain,
Steve Wofsy and their lab.
And we estimated that
a little less than 3%
of the amount gas that's
delivered into the service area
is leaked out.
So that may not sound
like a lot, the 3%,
but because of the power of
methane as a greenhouse gas,
it has an outsized effect.
And so that's why a 3%
turns into about 10%
of the total commonwealth's
greenhouse gas emissions
inventory at that level.
So if you took that 3%
leaked gas down to zero,
you'd save the commonwealth 10%
of its greenhouse gas emissions
inventory.
And about $90 million
dollars per year
was the cost of the
commodity at the time
that the study was done.
Gas is volatile so
that number changes.
AUDIENCE: But there's
another observation
in that, which is
that 3% just in itself
would reduce to peak load
demand for gas by 3%.
And when they talk
about new pipelines,
they're increasingly talking
about a 5% definciancy
in our peak load capacity level.
So you can definitely
mitigate the need
for disposing the new
pipelines if you were
to come out and fix the leaks.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: That is an
excellent, excellent point.
We'll do here and then there.
AUDIENCE: Don't
you have a problem
of how you put all
these dollars together,
because there's $90 million
dollars that I understand
that ratepayers paying the leak
gas that we don't know about.
We don't know her.
And then there's this fund that
they have for fixing leaks.
And then there's
the mountain lines
that they're using for
developing a new pipeline.
And those are all coming out of
different pocketbooks, I think.
And it seems that if
you don't figure out
how to put them
together, how about--
OK, stop making us pay $90
million for wasted gas.
Let's use the $90 million
and fix the leaks,
and then don't use
the money that we're
going to build a pipeline
for and fix the leaks.
So because this is all about
money at the end of the day.
It's all anybody
cares about when
you [INAUDIBLE] company,
either that or the people being
mad at them in the public, which
ultimately is about the money
issues as well.
So have you thought
about how you [INAUDIBLE]
to put those together?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
One of the things--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Well, no.
One of the things, I think,
that would be most effective
is if the utilities had to pay
for the cost of the lost gas.
If they did, as
soon as they did,
I think we'd see a massive
amount of repair happening
a hell of a lot faster.
That that's what
happened in Texas.
They passed a law saying that.
And within-- and I'm going
to get this wrong now--
within three years, they
had 50% of the leaks fixed.
So it's just incentives.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
What I heard was
on the day that the
legislature, the end
of the legislative session
last year, when the energy
omnibus bill was finally passed
at-- whatever-- two o'clock
in the morning, I think
that's when the provision that
would include the incentives,
the cost of the lost gas
gets shipped into the
companies was gone.
So there's a lot of
logging going on over who's
paying for the lost gas.
That's a problem.
AUDIENCE: Well, but
what you're saying
is that's the first
place to start, start
by not taking the $90 million
and using it to fix the leaks,
taking $90 million
and say ratepayers
you keep it in your
pocket until the gas
company's paying for it.
But that's a really simple-- any
legislator can figure that out,
or any member of the public
could figure that out.
You make it really simple.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: That was
the provision [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Well, I know.
But the public [INAUDIBLE]
in the middle of the night
is that the public is asleep.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Right, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Just when
they emit the gas.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So with
the infrastructure
being this old, I'm worried if
you fix the leaks in one spot,
because it's
[INAUDIBLE] of pressure,
then it will just create
leaks in other spots.
So has there been any
study of what happens
when you fix leaks?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Do
you want to take it?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
We both can answer.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: You go first.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: I
think a lot in Boston,
a lot of the
pressure in the pipes
is about half pound
per square inch.
So fixing a leak in
one spot is really not
going to make any
discernible difference.
And the pressure's supposed
to be maintained evenly
across the system, otherwise the
people at the end of the line
would not be getting any gas.
So there is the question that
hammering into the ground
and moving stuff
could potentially
displace a little bit of--
move the joint of
the pipe a teeny bit,
although I wonder if
that's actually true.
Your thought?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
It's a pressure-regulated
system.
So if you patch a
leak, they're just
going to turn down the
flow to maintain the-- so
it's not going to induce a
higher leak rate elsewhere.
But it is a Band-Aid
solution to patch,
because every 12 feet on a
cast iron pipe is a joint.
And you often have
a series of leaks,
so then you're
facing the question,
do you repair or replace?
And there's a whole other
set of considerations
in terms of money.
Cost.
And I'm still very ambivalent
about whether we should triage
the system that we
have as we transition
to electrifying
our heating system
and making the transition
to a clean energy--
a non-fossil energy--
or do we actually
invest in replacing pipes
that are going to be down
for another 30, 40, 50 years?
So, it's a tough call.
AUDIENCE: Is the technology--
are they discussing technology
and the composition of pipes
that would be more long-term
and less susceptible to--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Not really.
Plastic is what's
being put down now.
And it's not leaking
because it's new.
They don't really
know, as far as I know,
how acids in the soil
and weathering and all
of these kinds of things-- what
the influence on the plastic
will be.
There's nothing inherently
wrong with cast iron pipe,
except it's old.
If it was new cast-iron pie--
of course, that's more
energy intensive to make--
but it's really just
the age factor, I think.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Although
I just want to say,
I keep thinking
dentists can come up
with stuff that
can fix teeth that
are in saliva and acidic stuff
and under incredible pressure
and stuff like that.
Why can't anybody
come up with something
that we could just coat
the pipes on the inside?
So, you know, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was curious
how broad a number
of the people who have been
doing this sort of work, you
might have across the country--
other cities around the world--
are you in touch with folks?
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Mostly Massachusetts.
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
You know, the study
we did in Boston was the first
study of its kind in the world.
So things started bubbling out
from here, literally I guess.
But I think there's
been a very strong what
we call the gas leak's allies.
The working group that we have
that meets-- is it once a month
or once a week?
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Twice a month.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Twice a month.
This core group.
And Mothers Out Front
has been amazing
in terms of, essentially,
keeping that and growing
that network.
You know, you're seeing research
communities and other people
in the science community doing
this work in other locations.
I haven't quite seen the network
expand the way it has here,
but the other interesting
thing, I think,
is that we're also
realizing that there's
this urban to rural
interdependency.
And so the pipeline issues
connect us with, you know,
rural Western Massachusetts.
And the Kinder Morgan proposed
pipeline going in there.
The pipeline that
connects us, in Boston,
to New York, New
Jersey, Connecticut.
The Algonquin
Incremental Market.
The Spectra pipelines.
That we are connected across
the rural and urban communities
by the same infrastructure.
So I think that the fossil
fuel infrastructure expansion
physically starts to organize
a social network of resistance
that is co-located with that.
And that we're stronger
when we, as people, make
the connections that are being
made physically, to resist it
in a concerted fashion.
AUDIENCE: One more just
quick technology, though.
I read about it in
[INAUDIBLE] Apparently
there's a new kind of
robot that they have.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: The CISBOT?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That they can put into
the pipes-- that can fix leaks
from inside the
pipe, without having
to shut the gas line
down and without having
to dig up the streets.
But they are phenomenally
expensive robots, I guess.
So that struck me
when I read about it
as a significant ray
of hope that technology
could once again come to the
rescue here, so to speak.
If we had more robots, then it
might not be so economically
difficult for the utilities to
deal with the 20,000-odd leaks.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
That robot-- they have
to dig down to put it in,
and it only has a
limited expanse.
So it needs so much improvement,
it's stunning to me.
Maybe.
AUDIENCE: I'm from Chile.
I work for an oil
company in Chile.
It's an operation
company, and they'll
have pipelines in the city, but
only we extract oil and gas.
We detect a lot of leaks
of methane in operations,
and it's really,
really difficult
to solve the problems.
Sometimes you can
measure it in one corner,
but the leak is two
blocks to the other side,
because [INAUDIBLE].
And from the
perspective of the oil
and gas utility companies,
only the first--
the priority is
for the explosion.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
Yeah, of course.
AUDIENCE: This is the problem.
I can say 2%, 4%, 5%.
But that's OK.
It's the effort to
do the business.
When the general manager or
the manager of some assets
know that he has a waste--
structural waste in the area--
he's really charged
with this [INAUDIBLE]..
If you put this
information at an address,
they are ready to move forward.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Something
happened, because they know.
Something happened, [INAUDIBLE]
I work for the oil company,
but I know when you
have risk, [INAUDIBLE],,
you need to take this
risk into account.
[INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN PHILLIPS: I
would agree with that.
You know, there's a nexus of
issues associated with the gas
leaks at the local
scale, explosion risks,
risks to vegetation and trees--
that's local.
Air quality degradation is
more of a regional thing.
And then there's
the global issue.
And they're all issues, and
they should all be considered.
Because after our
Boston study, I
remember that I was on
Greater Boston, the TV show.
And the co-panelist
was the Secretary
of Energy and Environment
for Massachusetts.
And he said, thank you
for the work you're doing,
because you're giving me
a way to make this issue.
You know, because
the explosion issue
allowed him to push forward the
climate change part of this.
So, yeah, that's consistent
with what you're saying.
AUDIENCE: When you
[INAUDIBLE] have you ever
been talked to by
somebody walking along?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: All the time.
AUDIENCE: So, why is the
situation definitely like this?
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
Well, he's been--
Bob Ackley has been a lone
voice for the last 30 years
who has been struggling
to be not just
the only person who has
been calling this issue out.
And I think he feels--
I don't want to
speak for him, but--
when people started
to join with him,
that's when I think
he started to feel
some level of vindication.
That it's not just me.
So as this network has grown
larger, I think the changes--
the policy changes are happening
because it's just everyone
seeing that this is a problem.
He's been struggling
on his own for--
he worked for the gas
companies to do leak surveys.
So for much of his
career, he was basically
a worker for the gas company.
Here's the leak reports.
Here are the gas leaks.
And he would notice
trees were dying,
and that the gas companies
were not taking that seriously.
They're like, well, we're not
going to worry about that.
And that really bothered him.
So at some point, he defected
and went out on his own
because the trees were-- he
felt like his work wasn't
being taken seriously, and
so he struck out on his own.
It's one person and these
massive investor-owned
utilities that has
made it very difficult.
AUDIENCE: I saw your latest.
You tweeted it.
In Dedham?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that a new line?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yes.
Yes, that's the West
Roxbury lateral pipeline.
AUDIENCE: And now it leaks?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah, so
I'm going to just show it.
So we went out on Monday.
A while back.
Me and myself and my son.
So you see these spikes.
Something like this, right?
You see the red spikes.
And this is on a stretch of--
it's East Street in Dedham.
Very close to Dedham center,
right by where the Boston
and Providence turnpike--
whatever it's called--
fast-moving thing.
That stretch of East Street,
which is about an eighth
of a mile, is part of the
pathway of the new West Roxbury
lateral pipeline, which is a
750 pounds per square inch,
two-foot diameter
transmission pipeline
spur that has been
part of Spectra Energy.
It's their project to increase
the gas flow into Boston.
And what's really disturbing
about what we found on Monday
is that this is where,
in the last year,
they've trenched that entire
roadway and put this new pipe.
Then they covered it up, paved
new paving, new sidewalks,
but they left
leaking pipelines--
the low-pressure
distribution pipelines--
they left them
leaking, and that's
where there's all of these
leaks, one after the other.
And so it was a
missed opportunity.
If you're going to
dig up the street,
don't leave hundred-year-old
leaking pipelines there.
Fix it.
There's already patches,
now, in this new pavement,
which are going to mean
potholes are going to form soon.
AUDIENCE: Are these
leaks the spokes that
run off of the main pipeline?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: They're
the old distribution,
low-pressure pipelines,
that should've
been fixed at the same time that
they put the new pipeline in.
AUDIENCE: So two questions.
One, what's the name
of the instrument?
Are we going to
learn more about it?
And then two, how does
the EPA rule [INAUDIBLE]
impact any of this work?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: OK.
Yes, you get to go on the 31st.
AUDIENCE: I'm out of town, darn!
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Well,
we can arrange something
on another occasion, I'm sure.
But we get in the van, you
can see that the picture
that Audrey showed--
it's called a cavity
ring-down spectrometer.
That's the technology.
It's a laser technology.
It has a little chamber in
it that is evacuated down
to about one fifth of a whole
vacuum, so it's got about 20%
of the air molecules that
normal air would have in it.
So it's pulled
down to that level.
It's about a one-liter chamber.
And in that chamber,
there are three mirrors
that are pointed at each other.
And then they pulse
a laser into that
that is tuned to the unique
absorbance span for methane.
And that pulse of laser bounces
around the three mirrors.
That's called ringing down.
It's ringing in that
thing and bouncing around.
And the more concentration of
methane there is in that air,
the faster that pulse will decay
to zero, because the molecules
of methane are absorbing.
So if there's no
methane in there,
it'll take a long time
for that thing to decay--
that light pulse.
So that's the basic method
for the cavity ring-down
spectrometer.
AUDIENCE: Did you build
that, or [INAUDIBLE]
NATHAN PHILLIPS:
The manufacturer
for the instrument we
use is called Picarro,
and they're based
in Santa Clara.
The technology and the
patents were mostly
from Stanford
University scientists.
There's another firm that's
doing the same basic kind
of technology called Los Gatos
out in that area of California
as well.
There's a few different
flavors of this kind of method.
AUDIENCE: So do you think
that there's-- because this is
an expensive instrument.
How much does it cost?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: This
one was about $60k.
AUDIENCE: So I'm thinking
more in the community science
direction.
I think cheap lasers are
becoming real, right?
While maybe the
mirror configuration
might be the
expensive piece there,
is there a way to combine the
pulse lasers and, using data,
and other techniques to
get more cheap results?
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Well.
Do you want to answer?
I'm doing all the talking.
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Go ahead.
I'm happy.
NATHAN PHILLIPS: I'll just say
that I'm going to come back
to some comment there.
MIT, the people here?
The robot thing?
Yeah, we could have swarms
of little tiny robots fixing
pipelines, and MIT
is a great community
to come up with those
types of solutions.
And then, as well, low-cost
sensors that could do this
would unlock opportunities for
a much wider group of people
to be doing this stuff.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
And I don't think
they'll have to be expensive.
Like there's this
one technology where
it's just something that
goes on the pipe seal,
between the two joints, because
that's where most of the leaks
come from.
And if that link is broken,
it tells the office.
That's simple.
Let's do something
simple like that.
That's not expensive.
That's not hard.
AUDIENCE: You can detect
the leaks in operations,
we use infrared camera--
AUDREY SCHULMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can see the
flows, you couldn't measure--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Right.
AUDIENCE: Less flows, or more--
NATHAN PHILLIPS: Yeah.
More qualitative--
AUDIENCE: But you
can see, [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Very briefly mentioned
that the town of Brookline
has now passed two resolutions
opposing natural gas pipeline
expansion in Massachusetts.
We're the first community
to do such a thing where
a pipeline was not scheduled to
go through in our boundaries.
And we'd be happy to--
Brookline town meeting-- to
look into the issue of somehow
pressuring the gas
companies to more speedily
address some issues
and leaks in our town.
Kind of a general
pressure thing.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I think that's
something that Mothers
Out Front is already doing.
AUDREY SCHULMAN:
And we want that.
The more pressure they
have, the more everybody
takes it seriously.
As it should be.
PROFESSOR: So, we have three
more sessions on the 23rd,
which is the coming Monday.
We have a hack-a-thon.
and And again, we will be
playing with two different ways
of hacking with this data.
One is more data-centric,
more code-centric.
The other might be more
design charette-centric.
So--
AUDIENCE: Visualizing.
PROFESSOR: So
visualizing the data.
Again, depending on
what your interests are,
you can do one or the other.
Do sign up on the CLIAP site,
if you haven't already done so.
The next session, on the
31st is driving around town,
and smelling.
I think that's going to
be what we'll be doing.
And finally, on the first,
we will come back together
and say, what can communities
and citizens and scientists
do with this?
Can you take this to court?
So, how do you
build an ecosystem
that addresses these
challenges, and not
just do it individually?